[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful column written by bill
plaschke on
the passing of vin scully and
that show was meant to be a celebration
a couple of days ago because it should
be
because he went out on his own terms to
be able to work until you're 88 he was
94 when he passed away
nobody said a bad word ever about vin
scully what a wonderful person and i
thought bill plaschke captured
the life and times of ben and what he
meant to the city of los angeles also a
lot of people responded to brian
cranston the great actor who said i just
need an outlet i'm i'm shooting
a show in new orleans i can't come on
the show but i want to write something
and he wrote something really lovely
about what vin scully meant to him and
so many people in los angeles
had similar feelings about what vin
meant to him and i mentioned
those in los angeles are spoiled with
all the great voices you had and you had
them for decades
bill plaschke joining us around the horn
contributor and of course columnist for
the la times that's one of those i'm
guessing where you go how do i capture
this and do it
in a column i mean it's more of a it
feels like a 30 for 30 vin scully and
you're trying to capture him in a column
how challenging was that yeah it was so
it was so difficult dan it was so
he's been as much part of my life and
part of our all of our lives how do you
describe the soundtrack of your summer
how do you describe the
wallpaper in your living room and on the
summer night you know how do you
describe the uh the the uh
all the millions of words that he was
armed he was our muse and how do you how
do you capture that
and he was i think the thing i mean him
so different
is that he was so no longer say
different but made him so unique was
that he was so kind
and so gentle and so you know this is a
man
he he he called his own bobble head
night
and never said it was his bobblehead
night imagine that called the whole game
never once said it was his bobblehead
night would never do a book i begged him
to do a book with me would never write
never write a book how many how how many
people of his stature have now have not
written books he said i don't think
people aren't i don't think i'm that
interesting bill
he wouldn't come back on once he tried
to retire in 2016 he wouldn't come back
on and do any world series innings when
the dodge was rented he said no
that's my place is gone i'm just going
to get in the way he always thought he
was just going to get in the way
and you know little and then of course
the the crownies chris crowley
achievement out here
it was amazing everybody was when his
final game at dodger stadium that he
broadcast
he ended it
by singing
wind beneath my wings to the fans
it was the only misguided gesture of his
career because
we should have been seeing it to him but
that's how he felt he felt like the fans
were the ones who lifted him and carried
him through all this
his appreciation was never lost
and if you had a style like that now
nobody's going to hire you
right
yeah because one thing you d
he was he wasn't a homer he never in
fact
he never this is a little secret about
ben he never really
went to the clubhouse and never you know
the players
admired him
but didn't really like him for a long
time because he was critical of them you
know he was
he wasn't there you know he wasn't he he
he called the game right right down the
middle
and he told stories so he wouldn't
really call the game he told the stories
he used to tell me
god invented the foul ball for him
because every foul ball meant the story
could continue
and you would cheer for you'd walk right
right there and you listen to vintel's
story and you'd be cheering for the foul
ball and you know stories like i
remember the the one that i think it was
the diamondbacks brought in an
outfielder socrates burrito and i
thought oh god here we go
here we go
let's go vinnie and for 16 it's been all
about soccer teams
and foul ball after foul ball after foul
ball and yeah
god made the foul ball for many um
the matthew stafford elbow procedure now
feels like it's more than just a
procedure and then sean mcvay kind of
echoed that
uh
is this a big deal
yeah this procedure has implanted a
little bit of fear into all the rams
nation yeah
super bowl champion defending the world
champion the quarterback's got a bad
elbow uh that's a big deal it's a big
deal because
he's never dealt with this before at
this level
it's a big deal because mcveigh's never
coached a quarterback before this level
so it's almost like the blind leading
the blind they're having a tough time
trying to figure out how to get this
under control he threw a ball 50 yards
yesterday looked great
that's one pass in practice yeah what
happens with the regular you know rigor
of the of the nfl season
this is definitely an issue this is a
big issue that the bear is watching
because i think the rams just really
don't know they don't know what they're
going to get they don't know if they
have to do it is their business giving a
pitch count
i mean is he gonna be restrained he's
gonna be ready they don't know
and without matthew stafford and sean
mcvay's offense i mean
you know they don't win i mean it's
the season's over with so it's a big
it's a big deal
how much confidence do they have in john
wofford
i love john walford and i pushed for him
to replace jared goff back then but
wofford can carry out the offense he can
he can run the plays
but he can't throw the deep ball and he
can't make the big wow play and he can't
save him like stafford saved him so know
that confidence they're
they're a 500 team at best with wofford
in there and they're not a they're
they're they're barely a playoff team if
if at all it's because the quarterback
driven yeah team it's a quarterback
coach it's it's
that's
that's the reason they went and got
staff for going to super bowl did not
get him you don't win the super bowl
rams made moves in the offseason
knowing they're not going to have obj
but is there still a chance obj could
end up in this
on this roster later in the season
as a brilliant columnist who wrote that
they should never have signed obj and he
was a terrible for the team
that was one of my more regretful
regretful moments of the of the last
season uh i'm i'm all in oh come on obj
please come you'll be great i'll support
it i'm on the i'm i'm leading obj
bandwagon yeah this feels like i know
bjc they seem to like it except for me
you seem to like it out here
you don't like it you seem to like
everybody out here uh so i i think it's
very strong i mean you got to think
they're
they're looking at all angles now
they're trying to figure out how to
mitigate this because this isn't this is
a deal
yeah he's bill plaschke la times
columnist contributor to around the horn
does lebron feel like he's on the clock
here with this contract extension with
the lakers
not really i mean he's going to he's
going to end his career here the lakers
are going to take care of him he's just
waiting to see he'll sign at least a
one-year deal
probably with the option to see where
ronnie's going to go he wants brought to
play with ronnie
the lakers you know
they want him around they like him i
think they should trade him i think they
should get i think they should offer him
nothing and get rid of him and start
from scratch because they're not going
to win
but they're in love with the star power
they love within breaking the record of
korean's record next year and they would
be the one team
hollywood that would go out of their way
to make sure he and brian played
together and that's three years down the
road this is all leading to that so
he'll get he'll get what he wants they
they could you get for him bill if
they tried to trade him
i would think whoever's gonna get him
this year would be instant instant
championship contenders
while he's still healthy i mean you get
you get a couple front-line players and
some some draft capital i would think i
would think because he's guaranteeing
you
a trip deep in the playoffs if he has
the right surrounding cast
i mean i think i mean he was great last
year but who's going to pony up for him
that they won't decimate their roster
where they would be competing for a
championship yeah i don't know i've i've
given up hope i've banged the trade
lebron drum for six months now got no
takers so i don't uh
i've given up hope i can't tell you but
i gotta think there's somebody out there
that he would
he would come right in and step right in
there and maybe just draft maybe just do
draft picks for him yeah because that's
the thing
will he go
uh
you know with this player in power money
he might just say you know i'm not going
well i think they i think at this point
they want to keep him around to break
the record you know so that's a big deal
so and then and then maybe go next year
but i just don't see this
trying to acquiesce to him to make sure
he plays with brownie that's what this
extension is all about because he's
already in he's already guaranteed to
break the record in front of fans here
it's it's about the the next couple
years and whether he stays and it's
about brony
and i just don't think you tailor your
organization around the needs of a kid
who's a senior in high school right now
well you go back to kobe and it felt
like
they weren't going to win they knew they
weren't going to win but they wanted to
give you something to show up to see
therefore
they kept coming
and i've told genie this before i
criticized that move when it happened
but i i reneged i i went back on that
that was a brilliant move because they
gave us a 60-point game it gave us the
game against utah it gave us the goodbye
and that and so that that was worth the
48 million they gave kobe the last two
years of his contract wow lebron doesn't
have that connection here yeah i don't
think people are even that excited he's
gonna break kareem's record
i think as many people are cheering for
kareem's chair for lebron
i really think so dan so he you know i
think they're talking about giving a
kobe contract to a guy who doesn't have
the kobe magnetism or the kobe
connection that kobe had here
and it feels like you can't go a day
without russell westbrook being sent
somewhere
oh he's yeah he's not going i mean i
think they've given up on that i think
he's not going anywhere
and they're trying to trying to make it
you know trying to make it as pliable as
they can for him but i think if
darvinham
asked him to be andre iguodala
like use that as
i know that russ thinks he's better than
what he is but if you say look you can
play another five years in the nba
if you kind of modern model yourself
after that person who was a great scorer
made a lot of money was a big deal and
became a role player
and asked russ to do that
if not i he might not be in the nba
after this contract
well i agree but he think he's going to
listen to
darwin him he's leading us to frank
wohood in his name he's been through
four coaches in four years he didn't
listen to anybody
but yes he'd be great iguodala was a
great locker room guy
russ is a divisive locker room guy and i
can't just imagine i can't imagine
liquor media day that's going to be
bigger than a world series that's going
to be bigger than the opening of the the
football season with the rams and bills
russell westbrook and anthony davis
lebron james at laker media day that's
that's that's our super bowl right now
how nervous do you think the dodgers are
with what the padres did
they're very they're nervous about what
clayton kershaw did they were very
nervous about his back
leaving tobacco yesterday and i wrote i
told him dan you got to get a starting
pitcher you need starting pitching
helping the trade deadline they didn't
do it they didn't get it and now they're
in trouble now they're in trouble
because because clayton's with his back
issues he's probably out at least a
month
they may not get him back full strength
for the postseason they have julio
aureus is there one
someone bonafide starter that's healthy
and ready to go
you know they could be hurt and it comes
to short seasons in october they could
be really hurting
they're really worried about clayton
that's that's that worries them more
than padres i think the padres
think that i think they're still a year
away from from from actually challenging
the dodgers but they're they're worried
to death about clayton kershaw right now
you know the angels sort of put it out
there with shohei ohtani
let's just get a the room temperature
here um
let's look a couple years down the road
is shohei ohtani's next contract with
the angels
i believe it is i believe otherwise
already has done reno just gotta sell
the team if he gets rid of this if he
gets rid of this guy
remember what happened to the last team
that traded babe ruth they didn't win
for 85 years uh you don't tread troy
autonomy you just don't do it you build
around them you figure it out well they
traded one soto so
oh
you make you make better decisions yeah
you make better decisions no you just
show has different show hates twice the
player of soto is i mean literally twice
the player soto is
you don't trade trojan time that would
be
death to everything that the angels
stood for it would mean ardy would
probably sell the team he'd probably
have to get 15 before he sold so you
cannot you just cannot trade that kind
of asset is there any chance that ucla
is
not allowed to leave to go to the pac-12
i know usc is a private institution but
the governor has talked about
you know maybe
you know he wants answers here with ucla
leaving to go to the pac-12 well he's
just stamping his feet trying to get
some public okay voters trying to get
some attention they're going ucla is
going ucla was going a minute usc said
hey guys you want to come along with us
although ucla will tell you they they
were leading the lead leading that train
no no no dan
they got a call in the middle of the
night hey we're going to bring ten you
you went in sure okay we're in
and that's that's how that works they're
they're no they're definitely going and
if for nor the reason then as ucla
explained it
the of all the tv money will pay for
their all their olympic sports
all these non-revenue sports that could
have gotten cut out yeah they're all
being paid for now at ucla and so that's
huge for them there's no way any provost
or any trustee is going to go vote a
vote against that doesn't want to come
to a boat it's just a bunch of
hand rain and brain to the sky
good to talk to you again bill and uh
thanks for the column on on vin and uh
have a good weekend thanks yes it's been
a long tough week out here but you got
the padres in town this weekend
celebration of life event it should be a
great friday night it's your best ravine
if you can handle the traffic in the
bathroom
thank you bill bill
la times sports columnist and
contributor to espn's around the horn